[Music]
here we go again
sony have finally revealed the free
games for us playstation plus
subscribers for the month
of march 2021 like always we can
download these games from the first
tuesday of the month which is march the
2nd
you ready let's do this i can't believe
i'm saying this but on ps4 in march we
can get our hands on one of last year's
most anticipated games
final fantasy 7 remake you've likely
heard about the jrpg from back in 1997
and maybe you've played it too
the remake retells a portion of that
story but doubles down on the character
development and story
the rpg elements remain key but without
a doubt
this is as much an action game as it is
an rpg
playing as cloud strife we are recruited
into avalanche a group
facing off against the mega corporations
in the world you'll be blowing up a
reactor or two and wielding a sword
which is feasibly impossible to pick up
if you're worried about turn-based
combat
don't be everything has been updated to
allow for real-time action
as our abilities build up before we can
harness them
adding a different type of tactical play
than simply spamming a button repeatedly
we aren't stuck to one character either
the party members can be switched to on
the fly
if you're not too great with barrett you
know the guy with a gun for an arm
let the ai take over that person which
allows you to concentrate on the
characters you prefer
once you've been playing a few hours
though you'll be switching between
everyone instinctively
definitely give this a go even if final
fantasy games haven't been your jam in
the past
i promise it's worth it game number two
is here on the ps5
this is marquette a first person puzzle
adventure
how the heck can i explain this well one
example shows how the world is within a
world
here's a large block which requires
moving and to do that the player uses
a miniature model to move it and voila
in the real world the block has
moved to this goes further with a world
inside a world inside a world it's like
inception after learning how things work
in this environment you'll be using
different versions of each world to
impact your progress
like using a key from the upper world to
bridge across a gap
in the current world it's tough to
explain in 60 seconds but i think you
get the idea
marquette looks to test your logic
thoroughly
back over to the ps4 now and remnant
from the ashes
another role-playing action game but
this one is much more shooter-based
the game is best described as a
soulsborne game
but with guns remnant is said to be a
difficult game
in other words remnant will make you
fail and thus learn from your mistakes
and then adapt in your next encounter
difficulty should be expected
so if you're here for games to chill out
with maybe avoid this one
remnant utilizes randomly generated maps
which makes every encounter feel
familiar yet
unique and when coupled up with co-op
play this game is at its best
so to surmise if you're looking for dark
souls with guns
remnant is the game for you game number
four now and
holy heck psvr is getting some love this
is farpoint
back in 2017 this was revolutionary
stuff but four years later
it certainly feels old we joined the
space adventure on a hostile alien
planet and we use an assortment of
weapons and upgrades
to fight off the locals including a
spider big enough to give you
arachnophobia in addition to that single
player stuff there is a co-op mode which
adds much more replayability and teaming
up with a friend to strategize is great
fun
i guess all we need now is a friend rip
the dream
keep in mind farpoint is a 2017 game and
i think you'll enjoy this
but wait there's more we have a sneak
peek at april's ps plus with the
confirmation that ps5 owners will
receive oddworld
soulstorm on the day it releases that's
april the 6th
i'll tell you more about that nearer the
time just thought i'd give you a heads
up
and speaking of the ps5 remember last
month's ps5 game is here for a second
month destruction all stars a take on
destruction derby
but with a twist okie dokie doodoo
that's the games for the month
like usual sound off in the comments and
please rate the month i'm going to give
this
8.7 out of 10. i don't know where that
number came from what do you say
i'm adam from playstation grenade it's
been a pleasure i'll see you next time